Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速通知大家一个正在进行的好消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造能为你带来源源不断收入的管道，而不是没完没了地用时间换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“向持续性收入冲刺挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康从业者，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. with Dr. Marianne Durant Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都对你适用。还有由丽莎本人直接送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战赛，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特ント（Dr. Marianne Trent）博士一对一咨询一小时的机会。你想了解更多吗？当然想。前往我的Linktree“Dr. Marianne Trent”，或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有细节告诉你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。如果你正期待成为一名心理学家，那就让它成为你的指南吧。由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持。你好，欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》。
If you are listening on the day that this is released, it will be Monday the 9th of May, then you're in luck. You can listen. Come along live to the final planned compassionate Q&A, which you can grab via all of my socials, all of them. I'm on LinkedIn, which is Dr. Marianne Trent, and the same for Instagram, the same for Twitter. And then I am Good Thinking Psychological Services for both YouTube and for Facebook. If you're on YouTube, it's only fair to come along and subscribe. And whilst you're there, just like a bit of the content and flinging a few little nice comments.
如果你是在本期节目发布的当天收听，也就是5月9日星期一，那么你真走运。你可以聆听。来参加最后一次计划中的有同理心的问答直播，你可以通过我的所有社交媒体找到它，所有的。我在领英（LinkedIn）上叫Dr. Marianne Trent，Instagram和Twitter也是一样。YouTube和Facebook上我都是Good Thinking Psychological Services。如果你在YouTube上，顺便来点个订阅也是情理之中。顺便在那儿给点内容点个赞，留下几条好评。
You know, you know, it makes sense. And I don't often remind you of this, but all of the podcast episodes are available to watch on YouTube. If it's just me chatting, because frankly, I don't always want to put my makeup on. And yeah, so if it's an interview, it is usually stuff that you can watch me and the interview guest. But it's been a while since it's just been me. So I thought I'd check in with you, see how you're finding the guest interviews. How are you finding the podcast more generally as well? I would love any feedback that you've got. And if you really feel so inclined, if you've got like a spare couple of moments,
你知道的，这很有意义。我并不经常提醒你们，但所有的播客节目都可以在YouTube上观看。如果只是我在聊天，坦白说，因为我有时不想化妆。所以，如果是访谈节目，通常你可以看到我和访谈嘉宾。但已经有一段时间只有我一个人了。所以我想来看看你们，看看你们觉得嘉宾访谈怎么样。你对这个播客总体感觉如何？我非常欢迎你们的任何反馈。如果你真的有心，如果你刚好有几分钟空闲时间，
if you go along to the Apple podcast app, find my podcast, the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, and then scroll down right to the bottom, right below the trailer, and then you down right to the bottom, right below the trailer, and then you can rate. And if you've got a few more moments, you can leave me a little review. It would be so gratefully received. And if you really love the podcast, you could consider making a small donation to help cover the costs of making it and producing it and hosting it and transcribing it and all of that good stuff. If you would like to do that, you can head to my Linktree account, which you can
如果你打开Apple Podcasts应用，找到我的播客《有志心理学家播客》，然后滚动到最底部，就在预告片正下方，滚动到最底部，就在预告片正下方，然后你可以进行评分。如果你还有几分钟时间，你可以给我留下一个小小的评价。我将不胜感激。如果你真的很喜欢播客，可以考虑小额捐款，以帮助支付制作、出品、托管、文字记录以及所有这些好东西的费用。如果你想这样做，你可以前往我的Linktree账户，你可以在
find on all of my socials. The details for the Linktree account are also in the show notes for this episode. So today's episode is all about being, you know, there as a source of support for people. As we do when we're working in psychology, whatever branch of psychology you are in, and maybe you don't even work in psychology currently or maybe you never are going to because I know some people contact me and they're like I'm not ever going to be a psychologist but I do really enjoy listening um to your stuff so whoever you are, whatever you do, thanks for listening. Should just say, if the audio quality of this is not quite as good as usual, it's because, well, it's in keeping with the theme of today. Can't be bothered, okay? So I haven't got my professional mic and things out.
我所有的社交媒体上找到它。Linktree账户的详细信息也在本期节目的简介中。所以今天的节目全是关于，你知道的，作为人们的支持源泉。正如我们在心理学领域工作时所做的那样，无论你身处哪个心理学分支，也许你目前根本不在心理学领域工作，或者也许你永远不会，因为我知道有些人联系我说“我永远不会成为心理学家，但我真的很喜欢听你的东西”，所以无论你是谁，无论你做什么，谢谢你们的收听。我应该说，如果这段音频质量没有平时那么好，那是因为，嗯，这符合今天的主题。提不起精神，好吧？所以我没有拿出我的专业麦克风和设备。
I'm just going rogue with the AirPods. But it's on brand. It's on brand. And my lovely friend Michaela, who specializes in perfectionism and letting it go, I hope that she will absolutely salute this episode, even if the audio is not quite as good as it is when it's usually my solo endeavors you may have noticed at the beginning the audio was a little bit dodgier and then I invested in an expensive mic which didn't work very well I'd like to re-record and then we stumbled across a mic which worked really well but it is quite an involved process and today today, I just thought, oh, I don't want to. I don't want to get all the mic out. I'm just gonna, I'm just gonna go rogue with my, with my AirPods, and my Zoom account. So please forgive me. But yeah, I digress. So when we're working with clients in whatever capacity you're working with them you are always a human and as humans we don't always want to do our job okay and that is what today is all about you know so this was inspired um by me having a bit of a sad moment. I don't know if you guys have ever watched the most wonderful show.
我只是随性地用AirPods。但这很符合品牌调性。很符合品牌调性。我可爱的朋友米凯拉（Michaela）专门研究完美主义并学会放手，我希望她绝对会为这期节目点赞，即使音频质量不如平时我独自录制时那么好。你可能已经注意到，一开始的音频有点糟糕，然后我投资了一个昂贵的麦克风，但它不太好用，我想重新录音，然后我们偶然发现了一个效果很好的麦克风，但这是一个相当繁琐的过程。今天，我只是想，“噢，我不想。我不想把所有的麦克风都拿出来。我只想，我只想随性地用我的AirPods和我的Zoom账户。”所以请原谅我。但是，跑题了。所以当我们与客户合作时，无论你以什么身份与他们合作，你永远都是人，作为人，我们并不总是想做我们的工作，好吧，这就是今天的主题，所以这的灵感来源于我当时有点难过的心情。我不知道你们有没有看过最棒的剧。
It's called This Is Us and it's on Amazon. And I first discovered it when I was 36 and I was on sick leave from my job because my dad had just died. And I won't be spoiling anything if you haven't already watched it when I tell you that it's all about siblings who turn 36 in the first episode. And it felt so very appropriate and relevant to my life. And so it's felt like a really personal show for me. And then on Friday, I found out that this is going to be the last series of This Is Us. And I just wasn't ready for that. Because I'm sure originally, they said there was going to be like 10 series. And this is only series six. And so I wasn't ready. and so as I'm watching the episodes I'm feeling myself wanting to cry all the way through them because I'm just not ready to say goodbye to these characters
它叫《我们这一天》（This Is Us），在亚马逊上播。我第一次发现它时我36岁，当时我正因病休假，因为我父亲刚刚去世。如果你还没看过，当我告诉你第一集讲的是几个在第一集迎来36岁生日的兄弟姐妹时，我并没有剧透。这感觉非常贴切，与我的生活息息相关。所以这部剧对我来说有着非常个人的意义。然后到了周五，我发现这将是《我们这一天》的最后一季。我还没做好准备。因为我确信最初他们说会有大约10季。而这只是第六季。所以我还没准备好。所以当我观看这些剧集时，我发现自己一路都在想哭，因为我还没准备好和这些角色说再见。
because it feels so personal to me and my life and yeah this is kind of I guess relevant to psychology as well isn isn't it? Because sometimes, you know, we will have deep connections with our clients and the people we're working with and staff teams that we're working with, and we won't feel ready to say goodbye. And sometimes our clients won't feel ready to say goodbye either. And due to service pressures or due to service limits or due to you know you moving on or them moving on or you know them no longer meeting the criteria for service if they're getting better you may need to say goodbye to each other before you're ready to but this is a whole
因为这对我以及我的生活来说太私人了，是的，这某种程度上，我想这也与心理学有关，对吧？因为有时，你知道的，我们会与客户、我们合作的人以及我们共事的员工团队建立深厚的联系，而我们不会觉得准备好说再见。有时我们的客户也不会觉得准备好了说再见。由于服务压力、服务限制、或者由于你或他们的离开，或者你知道如果他们好转了，他们不再符合服务的标准，你们可能需要在准备好之前就互相道别，但这完全是另一个
separate issue that I might well come back to at the end of this podcast episode. But today's topic is how do we do this psychology or work malarkey when you're not feeling it, you know, because sometimes we want to lay on our sofa and, you know, this is us that's what we want to do sometimes we don't want to be you know getting all up in someone else's business and trying to sort out um tricky things and I guess the important thing to to work out here is if it is you know just an ebb and a flow issue. Sometimes we will feel further apart from, you know, wanting to be at work. And sometimes we will feel very unwell. And that's the difference, you know. So if you feel like you might be burned out, if you feel like you can't, you know, put your own things to one side for long enough to do therapy or intervention or assessment with a client,
独立的问题，我可能会在本期播客快结束时再谈到。但今天的主题是：当你没感觉时，我们究竟该如何应对这份心理学或工作呢？你知道，因为有时我们只想躺在沙发上，“我们这一天”就是我们有时想做的事，我们有时不想去卷入别人的事情，去尝试解决棘手的问题。我想这里需要弄清楚的重要一点是，这是否只是一种情绪起伏的问题。有时我们会觉得离“想要工作”的状态更远。有时我们会感到非常不适。这就是区别，你知道的。如果你觉得你可能精疲力竭了，如果你觉得你不能把自己的事情放到一边足够长的时间来对客户进行治疗、干预或评估，
then that is maybe a sign that you ought not to be at work at the moment. supervisor whether you could discuss that with your GP even about whether a period of time off work might be might be the best thing for you at this present moment however what I'm talking about is the general malaise of day-to-day life and on the whole even on days that I think, oh, I'd rather stay in bed today. And you might be like, I can't believe this qualified clinical psychologist is saying that. Because I know when I, before I became a qualified psychologist, before I became a trainee, I kind of was thinking, you know, this is the holy grail when I'm a trainee, when I'm qualified, you know, life will be amazing. And I will have a spring in my step every day. And, you know, and all of the traffic lights will be on green when I come to them. And
那么这可能是一个信号，表明你目前不应该去上班。跟你的督导商量一下，甚至与你的全科医生探讨一段时间的休假是否对你当前这个阶段是最好的选择。然而，我所说的是日常生活的普遍倦怠，总的来说，即使在我觉得“今天我宁愿呆在床上”的日子里。你可能会想：“我简直不敢相信这位合格的临床心理学家会这么说。”因为我知道，在我成为合格的心理学家之前，在我成为实习生之前，我曾以为，你知道的，当我成为实习生、当我合格时，这就是圣杯，生活将会无比精彩。我每天都会迈着轻快的步伐，交通信号灯在我面前全都是绿灯，并且
I'll be so happy. I will just want to skip everywhere, you know, like my five-year-old does, which is adorable. But yeah, I am not quite so perky as my five-year-old quite a lot of the time. Life will get its dents in you, whether you are doing the job you want to do or not. And so how do we go about doing everything we do if you're not really feeling it on any given day? And I will share my little hints and tips with you after this short break. So have a little listen and I will see you on the other side of this. We hope you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective.
我会非常高兴。我只想到处蹦蹦跳跳，就像我五岁的小女儿那样，这太可爱了。但是，是的，我大部分时间可没有我五岁女儿那么朝气蓬勃。生活总会给你带来打击，无论你从事的是你想要的工作与否。因此，如果在任何特定的日子里你真的没有感觉，我们该如何着手做我们所做的一切呢？在短暂的休息之后，我将与大家分享我的小提示和建议。所以请稍事聆听，我们在另一边见。我们希望你获得资格。所以来看看。就在这本书里。这是《临床心理学家合集》。
It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. My name is Diakolola Amujam. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to becoming a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK, I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information on the UK DeclinSci application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both qualified and training
这是《临床心理学家合集》。我的名字叫迪亚科洛拉·阿穆贾姆（Diakolola Amujam）。我最近刚从爱尔兰获得心理学学位。我也是一名有志成为临床心理学家的学员。玛丽安博士的书《临床心理学家合集》在我成为临床心理学家的这段旅程中对我有很大帮助。由于我计划在英国继续攻读研究生，我发现这本书提供了有关英国DeclinSci申请流程的深入信息，这极其有用。我很喜欢阅读合格的和实习的
clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favorite part of the book as everyone's story was different and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology journey. I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. okay so when i am well enough to be at work i do honestly find um that once i start a session with a client that any feeling of rather being on the sofa dies away you know it's not an issue anymore I genuinely enjoy my job um I really enjoy creating content for you as well so although although I was feeling
临床心理学家的经验。各种各样的自述是我最喜欢的部分，因为每个人的故事都不同，它为临床心理学之旅提供了令人惊叹的见解。我绝对会向任何对心理学感兴趣并渴望成为临床心理学家的人推荐这本书。以及能帮助你获得资格的经验。所以来看看。就在这本书里。这是《临床心理学家合集》。这是《临床心理学家合集》。好吧，所以当我身体状况足以支撑工作时，老实说我发现，一旦我开始与客户进行一次会话，任何想呆在沙发上的感觉就会烟消云散，你知道的，这不再是个问题了。我真心热爱我的工作。我也真的很喜欢为你创作内容。所以虽然虽然我当时感觉
like I'd rather watch This Is Us um once I get started I really enjoy it um and I speak to you on a weekend and I do usually record these midweek but you maybe have to hear in my voice um that I haven't I haven't been fully well this week. So I kind of felt OK. But as one of my clients said, it sounded like I'd been left in the rain outside because my voice was very squeaky and had a bit of a cough and a bit of a sniffly nose. So I wasn't really podcast ready in the week. So it's led to me just having a bit more of a hustle to get this done. But I really am enjoying the consistency of this podcast. you know I created the first eight and they were good to go um uh and you know I probably should have recorded more at that point I did did some along the way but um it's got to the stage now
自己更想看《我们这一天》，但一旦开始，我真的很享受。我是周末和你说话的，我通常在周中录制这些，但你或许能在我的声音里听出，我这周身体没完全好。所以我感觉还行。但正如我的一个客户所说，听起来我好像被忘在室外的雨里了，因为我的声音非常尖，有点咳嗽，鼻子还带点鼻音。所以在周中我其实还没准备好做播客。所以这导致我必须更加紧凑地完成它。但我真的很享受这个播客的连贯性。你知道的，我创作了前八期，它们已经准备好了。而且，你知道，我当时可能应该录更多的。我一路上做了一些，但，嗯，现在到了这个阶段
where um yeah I'm I'm running out of um of already uh created content and I'm having to do this one um the weekend before it's um due out so um you know this is you know just pulling out the bag real world style but um I really you know I thought I could give it could give it a miss for one week and I thought I don't want to I want the consistency of showing up for you week in week out um because I know that many of you, because you've told me, you lovely people, are really enjoying having this podcast as part of your weekly routine. So many of you are listening to it on your commute, as you go to work, perhaps on a Monday. Some of you are running to the sound of my voice. I don't know what your tempo is like. Because I've also been told I'm quite relaxing to listen to.
嗯，我快要用完现成的已创作内容了，我不得不在它发布前的那个周末来做这一期。所以，你知道的，这纯粹是现实风格的临场发挥。但我真的，你知道，我曾想过我可以停播一周，但我转念一想，我不想。我希望保持每周按时为你们呈现内容的连贯性，因为我知道你们很多人，因为你们告诉我，你们这些可爱的人真的很享受把这个播客作为你们每周日常生活的一部分。你们很多人在通勤时收听，在上班的路上收听，也许是在周一。有些人伴随着我的声音跑步。我不知道你们的节奏是怎样的。因为我也被告知我的声音听起来很放松。
Maybe you're all about the jingles. I don't know. But yeah, you know, I've become the fabric, not the fabric. That sounds really big headed. I've become some of the fabric of your day to day lives, which is a real honor, you know, a real privilege. And as I record this right now, we are at about 5,700 downloads. And so this is, you you know this is really exciting I'm really honored that so many of us so many of you are really valuing and enjoying the content and it means a great deal to me that you listen to it that you like it and that you tell me that you like it as well. So thank you from the bottom of my heart. But yeah, so thinking about how we deal with this stuff, you know,
也许你们都很喜欢片头曲。我不知道。但，是的，你知道的，我已经成为你们日常生活的一小部分，不是“结构”，听起来好像我很自大。我已经成为你们日常生活的一部分，这真的是一种莫大的荣誉，你知道的，真正的特权。就在我录制这段音频的时候，我们的下载量已经达到了约5,700次。所以这，你知道的，这真的很令人兴奋。我很荣幸你们这么多人真正重视和喜爱这些内容，你们听它，喜欢它，并告诉我你们也喜欢它，这对我意义重大。所以发自内心地谢谢你们。但是，是的，所以在思考我们如何处理这些事情时，
so sometimes it can be really interesting and useful, in fact, to have conversations about this sort of stuff in supervision with your supervisor. Thinking about, you know, whether this shows up more for some clients than others. So this is where the practice of, you know, perhaps having a reflective journal can be useful as well. So you cannot um making notes about clients so that i had that so that they are identifiable um but you you know one way of doing that is if you tended to see the same client you know every tuesday morning at 9 15 then you could write you know i notice that you know my you know 12 30 on a friday client or whatever um i often feel like i you know i can't be bothered um and maybe you know maybe that's about the time so maybe you're hungry um you know or maybe it's post lunch slump and you're just like having a really kind of slumpy, you know, maybe you're just digesting
有时候，在督导中与你的督导就这类事情进行对话，其实是非常有趣且有用的。思考一下，这是否比在某些客户身上表现得更明显。所以这就是进行反思日志记录可能派上用场的地方。所以你不能做关于客户的笔记，以免他们被识别出来。但你知道，其中一种方法是，如果你倾向于每周二上午9点15分见到同一个客户，那么你可以写下，“我注意到，你知道的，周五12点30分的那个客户或者其他什么，”我经常觉得自己“提不起劲”。也许，你知道的，这与时间有关，所以也许你饿了，你知道的，或者也许是午饭后的低谷，你只是处于一种无精打采的状态，你知道的，也许你只是在消化
your food. And so all of the brain power you'd usually have has disappeared to your stomach. And so you might just find that you're feeling a bit sluggish. So yeah, it's not always necessarily about the client. Sometimes it's about the time of day. Sometimes it's about the emotional load of everything else on your caseload as well. So maybe you're really enjoying, you know, the therapy work that you're doing, but maybe you're finding the team harder work or you are finding it difficult with your supervisor or you're feeling generally a bit pressured or unsupported. So it's not always about the clients. But if it is, you know, you notice in your reflective to be the same client that you are finding it hard to feel energized by, then it's definitely worth discussing that in supervision. And it might also be worth thinking about what that client brings to the room as well. And a virtual room counts as a room as well.
食物。所以你平时通常拥有的大部分脑力都跑去胃里了。因此你可能会发现自己感觉有点迟钝。所以，是的，这并不一定总是关于客户。有时是关于一天中的时间。有时也是关于你工作量中其他事情的情感负担。所以也许你真的很享受你正在做的治疗工作，但也许你觉得团队工作更难，或者你发现与督导相处困难，或者你普遍感到有些压力或缺乏支持。所以这并不总是关于客户。但如果确实如此，你知道，你在反思中注意到似乎是同一个客户让你很难感到充满活力，那么绝对值得在督导中讨论这一点。也值得思考一下那个客户带进房间的东西。虚拟房间也算是一个房间。
You know, are they low energy? Are they needing more from you? Are they leaving you feeling drained? Are you finding that you're having to stifle yawns as you're together? And if that's happening, it can often be worth thinking about whether there is a role for you. So I'm not saying there isn't a role, but whether a role is being left open for you. Because if you're feeling redundant, you know, you're making you feel like you want to yawn, then it might be that you're being talked at and any kind of opportunity that you have to try and open up the conversation or have a more functional helpful session is being shut down or can't be responded and it's perhaps feeling a bit more one-sided and so that can feel a little bit less than exciting um you know if you find yourself clock watching then that is not good use of your time and it's not great use of the client's
你知道，他们能量低吗？他们需要你付出更多吗？他们让你感到筋疲力尽吗？你发现自己在一起时不得不强忍哈欠吗？如果这种情况发生了，通常值得思考一下这其中是否有属于你的角色。所以，我并不是说没有角色，而是思考是否有一个为你敞开的角色。因为如果你感到自己很多余，你知道，这让你想打哈欠，那么可能是对方一直在对你喋喋不休，而你任何试图开启对话或进行更具功能性、更有帮助的会话的机会都被扼杀了，或者无法得到回应，这或许会让人觉得有点偏向单方面，因此这可能会显得不那么令人兴奋。你知道的，如果你发现自己在看表计时，那说明没有充分利用你的时间，对于客户来说也不是什么好事。
time as well you know and people often um will start therapy with me and they're like oh I know this is going to get worse before it gets better. But my take on that is that with appropriate warming up to each other and absolutely with the appropriate stabilisation, there might well be some tricky realisations along the way, but I would really hope, certainly now that I've been qualified for 11 years almost, I would really hope that my clients are now comfortably staying within their window of tolerance by the time we get to anything tricky. sometimes I find that I'm having to undo or redo stuff that's been done not quite so um skillfully in the past that has left clients feeling um vulnerable scared um you know out of control and as a result a bit terrified actually um so yeah when when clients are coming to you you know almost ready to be hurt I think that that's our um our lead to do stabilization work and to really make sure
时间也是如此，你知道的，人们经常会开始接受我的治疗，然后他们会说，“哦，我知道情况在好转之前会先变糟。”但我的看法是，通过彼此充分的预热，绝对加上适当的稳固，这一路上可能会有一些棘手的认识，但我真的希望，特别是现在我已经合格快11年了，我真的希望当我们要处理任何棘手的事情时，我的客户现在能够舒适地停留在他们的耐受窗口内。有时我发现我不得不撤销或重做过去做得不够熟练的事情，那些事情曾让客户感到脆弱、害怕，你知道的，失去控制，结果甚至有些恐惧。所以，是的，当客户来找你时，你知道，几乎随时准备受伤，我认为这是我们的指引，要去进行稳固工作，并且真正确保
that the client can handle thinking about these difficult things by the time you actually get around to them. One of my top tips for just making sure that you are managing things okay is if it's in keeping with your requirements at your individual work, check in supervisor check with the management if i am taking annual leave then i will usually try to leave the first day of annual leave clear in my diary so that i can battle through the email backlog so that i can fight any fires that might have um you know broken out in my absence um and so that I can probably finish reports I need to do um and paperwork like that like and paperwork and bits and so that I can finish any paperwork and bits and pieces and just make sure that I am as available as possible to clients rather than fretting about what might be at the bottom
客户在真正面对这些困难事情之前，已经能够应付自如。确保你一切处理得当的顶级技巧之一是，如果符合你各自工作的要求，与督导核对，与管理层确认，如果我要请年假，我通常会尽量在日程表上把年假的第一天空出来，以便我可以处理积压的电子邮件，这样我就可以扑灭在我缺席期间可能爆发的任何火灾，并且这样我可以完成我需要做的报告和诸如此类的文书工作，比如文书工作和琐事，这样我可以完成任何文书工作和零碎的事情，并确保我对客户尽可能地保持可及性，而不是去担心收件箱底部可能有什么。
of my inbox because when I've worked in mental health services you know you go off for a week and you hope everything will be okay but you know you don't know what emails you might have had and so yeah my little kindness to myself has been to plan that time in. And similarly, on occasions where I have left jobs and where I have left clinical placements on training, I have tried to give myself two solid weeks of non-client contact at the end of any contract because these reports do take time you know sorting through all the stuff to shut down your role and to leave things safe and write care plans and discharge letters and you know have goodbye lunches with your team and things like that takes time um and so yes you you know that is potentially two more weeks worth of where you could be seeing clients but this stuff matters
因为当我曾在心理健康服务机构工作时，你知道的，你休假一周，你希望一切都会好起来，但你不知道你会收到什么邮件，所以，是的，我对自己的一点小贴心就是把这段时间规划好。同样，在我离职以及在培训期间离开临床实习的场合，我曾试图在任何合同结束时给自己留出两周完全不接触客户的固实时间，因为这些报告确实需要时间，你知道，要整理所有东西来关闭你的角色，让事情安全交接，写护理计划和出院信，与你的团队举行告别午餐之类的，这些都需要时间。所以，是的，你知道的，这可能又是两周本可以用来接待客户的时间，但这些事情很重要。
you do need to have all the stuff I just mentioned in place you know it makes you don't want to be writing that from home you know when you're not being paid to do it um you want to be able to use your you know your compassionate well-rested self um in that important communication with your clients i love writing therapeutic letters. I really, you know, I really enjoy that. And I often do that with a client as well in one of our final sessions. But if I haven't done that, or if I need to have a more formal closing report, then that needs to be written. And that does take time. So please do give yourself time as you wind down from holidays and as you wind down from work roles altogether. Before you move on to a new and exciting work role, it can be tricky to stay with your head in the game when you've got your sights set on a new or different role but
你确实需要把刚才提到的所有事情都准备好，你知道的，你肯定不想在家里写这些，你知道的，在没有报酬的时候；你希望能够用你那充满同理心、休息充分的自我，与客户进行那重要的沟通。我喜欢写治疗信。我真的很，你知道，我真的很享受这个。我经常在最后几次会话中与客户一起做这件事。但如果我还没有这样做，或者如果我需要写一份更正式的结案报告，那么这就必须写。这确实需要时间。所以请在假期结束后放松时，以及完全结束工作岗位时，给自己留出时间。在你转向一个新的令人兴奋的工作岗位之前，当你把目光投向新职位或不同职位时，要保持专注可能会很棘手，但是
um yeah whatever's going on for you right now um you know sending you my good wishes and my compassionate vibes as ever um thank you for listening to today um i have no idea how long this episode is currently and I know I started off talking about something at the beginning and I said like oh that's kind of not related I maybe come back to it but it might be that I need to I didn't write it down it might be that I need to do a new podcast episode on that um so um I hope you this helpful. If you've got any feedback for me, please, please do let me know. All reviews and testimonials are so gratefully received. Yeah, and if you are on my LinkedIn, Dr. Marianne Trent LinkedIn, you can actually write me a testimonial on there as well. And the way that you do that is you go to my profile page and then you scroll down, down, down, down, past the skills.
嗯，无论你现在正在经历什么，你知道的，一如既往地向你致以我的美好祝愿和同理心；谢谢你今天的收听。我不知道这一集目前有多长，我知道我一开始谈论了一些事情，我说，“哦，那不太相关，我以后可能会回过头来讲”，但可能我需要，我没把它写下来，我可能需要为此做一期新的播客节目，所以，希望你觉得这有帮助。如果你对我有任何反馈，请务必告诉我。所有的评价和推荐我都非常感激。是的，如果你在我的领英上，即Dr. Marianne Trent的领英，你实际上也可以在上面给我写推荐信。方法是进入我的个人资料页面，然后往下滚动，一直滚动，越过技能部分。
And then you will see where some other people have written recommendations and you just create your own. And then I'll be able to approve that and add that to my profile and everybody will have a great day that's what I'm saying okay thank you so much for being part of my world if you are listening at any point other than the 9th of May then you should be able to watch all of the compassionate Q&As on replay by going to the playlist on my YouTube which is Good Thinking Psychological Services. But yeah, whatever your feelings, stay kind to yourself and know that you're only having these thoughts
然后你会看到其他人写推荐的地方，你只需创建你自己的。然后我就可以批准并将其添加到我的个人资料中，每个人都会度过美好的一天，这就是我想说的。好的，非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。如果你在5月9日以外的任何时间收听，你应该能够通过访问我的YouTube播放列表（Good Thinking Psychological Services）来观看所有有同理心的问答回放。但是，无论你的感受如何，请对自己好一点，并知道你产生这些想法只是因为
because you're human. So if some days you can't really be bothered, you know, that is just because the way that our brains are put together. But if you find that those days are becoming more and more common, then it's a good idea to chat that through but with your supervisor it might even be useful to get some therapy yourself just think about what that might be about because we want you to not to burn out in this career we want you to feel like generally speaking it's really something
你是个人。所以如果有些日子你真的提不起劲，你知道，那只是因为我们大脑的构造方式。但如果你发现这些日子越来越常见，那么最好与你的督导聊聊，甚至自己去做点心理治疗，去思考一下这可能意味着什么，因为我们希望你在这段职业生涯中不会精疲力竭，我们希望你总体感觉这确实是一件
that you are impassioned about and honestly that is the way I feel about most of my days so yeah I want you to want you to feel the same but yeah thank you so much for listening and I will look forward to speaking to you again soon don't forget that new episodes drop 6am every Monday UK time. And if you subscribe, it will come straight to you. Take care. Have a good day. Bye. side to be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with Dr Marianne Trent my name is Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and
让你充满热情的事情。老实说，这就是我对绝大多数日子的感受。所以，是的，我希望你也觉得如此。但非常感谢你的收听，我期待很快再次与你交谈。别忘了新节目在每周一英国时间早上6点发布。如果你订阅了，它会直接发送给你。保重。祝你有美好的一天。再见。在获得资格的道路上，这是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的《有志心理学家播客》。我的名字叫亚娜（Jana），我是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现其中所有不同的故事非常有趣，以及
how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
人们是如何成为临床心理学家的。这让我大为惊叹，原来有这么多种不同的途径可以到达那里，而且并没有成为其中一员的完美方式，这让我充满了信心，觉得自己并没有做错，并减轻了自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你翻开这本书，你就不会把它放下。本集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子来发表评论。